okay hi everyone we are looking at
chemistry functionality for upcoming
versions of language and
um
wow okay seems like we have a bunch of
let's see where are we starting here
atom labels is that where we're starting
right
so this is the analog of vertex labels
right and it uh it definitely uses a lot
of the same machinery as vertex labels
under the hood except it goes in a step
further and uh if you just um vertex uh
vertex labels doesn't really try and
find a position for the label that uh
doesn't conflict with the
the lines drawn and so we go a step
extra to try to do that here but you're
not succeeding in that case oh no so
that the first is an example of what uh
if i just use the placement straight
from graph plot
but then okay so so to me this is very
interesting functionality for graph plot
two
has somebody fed this back to charles
and that team
no i do need to get in touch with him
for a few things no no no no that's not
what i'm talking about if you've got a
way to actually label a graph that has
the labels not i mean maybe it's
specific to chemical grafts which are
plain well but they're not necessarily
planar but their
chemical graphs
have
do what special features do chemical
grafts have with respect to this
labeling i mean they're already so laid
out that often is a place in the regular
graph it's not obvious there exists one
i mean so with a chemical graph you
definitely generally want things to be
like 120 degrees with a few exceptions
uh here you specifically want to look
and see if there's a charge and if so
you avoid the uh after
right position or let's see after above
that type of thing i mean the main thing
uh holding that back though would be
that the um
uh the compiled code that uh iterates
over the the edges and the
isn't in uh
the kernel it's in uh c plus plus an
access via library link
so it could be used i could write a
wrapper function but yeah i'm not the
the implementation is not the important
part the the the important part is is
this a useful
layout capability for ordinary graphs
and if we should determine if the answer
is yes
only for a subset of possibly cars that
are i understand but
the same but that's true for
oh don't do this to me okay whatever
so um i'll send an email to the uh to
the discrete math group about the uh
labeling
okay fine all right okay anyway so
this is
okay i mean by the way i think that's
too far away
yes
and and what are we doing i mean how are
we like
are we doing a graphic design review or
how are we how are we determining
answers to questions like that
so after this meeting i was going to
contact uh design and ask them about the
the appropriate size for the fonts and
the appropriate uh default style but i'm
i think
some of these are sort of too far away
and this one looks like
you know this is like well that one
might be like
you know tritium or something
agreed um as you know it's it's tricky
uh
so but uh figuring out how big your
label is and then moving off from there
but i do uh but yeah
i'm always trying to improve it well
right but i mean there's ways in graph
with placed for example placed has a way
of i mean i assume
that
you will support in atom labels the same
thing
that vertex labels supports which is the
big list of
uh put this label at this position right
but this
okay so if you do that placed has
special purpose um placed is capable of
having special purpose tags in it for
different kinds of situations so you
could have something which is a very
chemistry oriented placed
did you see what i'm saying i do i do
um right so uh so actually so one
example there of something that isn't
supported in graph uh
but uh would be useful here would be
placed uh with subscript
as the uh the second option
sounds good to me yeah i mean right so
you can
yeah i mean in general it's actually
using uh so graph supports so many
different placed specifications that i'm
actually i went in and i'm using the the
func same functions they do
so as to uh
okay fine oh i see you already i i
didn't i okay so great so you've already
got a bunch of these
yeah and so between now and the code
freezes when i have to make um um what
do you call it uh the bond labels work
as well
um okay so so this is a um
so you've got atom labels and then you
would have
uh and then you have bond labels also
right but i um
so currently bond labels will just place
them directly on the center of the bond
which is what graphpod does but it's
well not what we want to do and so we
need to
and placed above and right
don't work currently in uh
in graph what's the analog of highlight
graph for a chemical
there isn't one so you would just call
uh you call molecule plot and give a
pattern as the second argument and it
highlights
some part
okay
that's right because these are molecule
plot outputs which are graphics not
graph objects
correct i have a question
i mean if i take that molecule and i say
graph of that molecule
do i get a graph right now because it'd
be really nice if i did
no i believe you have to call molecule
graph
what do you mean molecule graph
here rate
i didn't even know there was a molecule
graph but okay why is it why isn't it
just graph of that molecule why doesn't
that just work
i have mentioned this uh to charles um
not up to charles really is it is it an
up value thing
so i could yeah i i could make enough
value um but so i think you should agree
with charles how you're going to do it
because i think it's a desirable thing
to have
now if i have here if i say vertex does
why did this not preserve
i think that this should preserve the um
uh
molecular graph should preserve that's
really crummy i mean i think it should
preserve the the coordinates why not why
not give it molecule plot coordinates in
the graph here
so that uh that is a good point um
i don't know it does it let's see so it
handle it
it brings over any annotations uh that
are intrinsic to the molecule but it
doesn't bring over the coordinates so if
you ask for the annotation rules of that
or
um i guess i guess options is how you
access so all of the the uh
the identity of the the atoms and bonds
are listed as annotations in that
is that the way that they're okay i mean
i don't know if that's the best way to
do that and like a double bond is it
indicated with
is it indicated with two no it doesn't
seem to be indicated with two
what's it's right why isn't that a
double double edge there
because it's uh let's see so the edge
has an annotation of uh bond type goes
to double okay so it's important to me
okay all right fine there might be a
method option
but i don't have it okay but i i feel
strongly that this that graph of
molecule should just work and should
preserve the coordinates
and how far do you want to go back if
you assume have done this and then you
make molecules of percent
i don't think that has to work i mean
okay
it would be nice if something like that
worked but um i i don't know i mean
is it possible that that could work
because of the annotations it generally
does
okay well fine if it can work it can
work but if it doesn't have annotations
what are you going to do
we talked we did discuss this a while
ago you uh uh so it it assumes carbon
hydrogen's hanging off where they need
to hang off but what if there's a
valence 5 node
right so that's that's that becomes the
point where options would be useful like
if there was a graph molecule function
that had
options which were uh automatic valence
rules or valence replacement rules yeah
right that seems like not a bad idea but
i think that
and you know at the first instance
molecule of graph
could do the right could do the obvious
thing
and just give an error when it doesn't
work
i believe i mean so to the most part i
believe it should at the moment but i
mean if you gave it something like
complete graph five it it should it
might puke
what sorry what would work so if i take
molecule of this
oh
splatteroo okay
well
okay
yeah okay
but it's really important that you
preserve the coordinates here i think
okay yeah
okay let's keep going here
lovely
and so uh so the one specification
that's uh really uh unique to molecules
here not in graph is uh that you can put
um
um the atom index you can use uh um so
instead of the quote atom index there
you could use molecule property of
formal charge
or any particular atom uh based well
what are you showing that so if we go
down
what does molecule property wait a
minute so this is
wait a second that that's a function
isn't it molecule property that it's a
wrapper i mean it's inert um it's it's
yeah it
it's just a representation of the
property um
in retrospect i might not have created
that symbol
but
it is so molecule property of a molecule
like um
of a
the string then applied to a molecule or
a list of molecules returns the value
well it's the same thing as entity
property it is modeled after that yeah
but it only needs one argument because
it's
because it's always about a molecule
right
but in this case it allows you me to uh
um
to find any instance on the right hand
side within the the atom labels of
molecule property and then go in grab
those values and resubstitute them in
such a shame we don't have muonic
chemistry and uh hyper on chemistry and
all that kind of stuff then we would
have to have a new never mind i'm just
i'm just kind of joking but we just keep
going we will uh we will get there
right there we've got other things we
need to go and i mean i'm thinking in
bigger directions generally like with
crystal structures or with
macromolecules but we could also get
smaller
or metals
yes
the
you know ethan on our live stream is is
saying there should be machine learning
for molecules
maybe we can say something about what's
happening with that
right so uh so i need to schedule a
meeting with you i have i mean so we
have uh i have a function that needs
reviewed for uh for uh generating
features
okay
which is so that is what we need for
doing machine learning
of i don't know uh you know
this quite whatever it's called
quantities cusa type stuff is that right
right so that's one of the so
machine learning with uh with molecules
is not nearly as uh as mature and
it doesn't produce as many amazing
results as with images but uh so so
people are still really trying to figure
out ways of featurizing the the molecule
and they're um
every paper comes up as their own and
they're they're not yeah well look the
primary point is that image processing
you know image stuff is basically you're
trying to act like a human
in doing these things with molecules
there isn't any human in the loop so
there's no guarantee you know insofar as
neural nets
vaguely do something similar to brains
it's sort of therefore unsurprising that
image processing is something you can do
with them it is by no means self-evident
that you can do things with molecules
with them
it seems to be the case but it is much
less self-evident so to speak
and
i think a lot of it depends on i mean do
you choose some kind of featurizer that
is uh that captures the chemistry that
you're looking for
but
um
when we were doing this sort of stuff uh
when i was in the pharmaceutical
industry we would choose our features
that would be appropriate for the
problem we were working on
yes as well as the particular metric uh
the similarity measure and the uh
distance measure
right
right so so next week uh i'd like to
show you the basically a function uh
called molecule features which acts as a
an operator it is a function that takes
parameters
and uh um
and when applied to a molecular list of
molecules returns uh
the um the numeric array the relevant
numeric array all right so let me just
understand what you're doing here so
this is atom labels
what is this this is a
this is
so an atom
index you're saying atomic number is
i mean atom index would be one thing you
could give us a value of atom labels
that means put the atom index as the
atom label this is saying put the atomic
number
of the atom
as the atom label correct yes
okay
and it's kind of nice there's a molecule
property wrapper here
that at least is optionally available
because that allows you to say i mean if
i happen to want to write the word
atomic number
as the label of an atom i'm toast at
this point
oh no not no because this is because
atom labels could be a list of atom
labels
or rather
presumably
atom list okay given a molecule let me
let's get very basic here given a
molecule ah this isn't a molecule oh i
wish this was just a molecule i wish i
could pick this up and just put it
somewhere why can't i do that so if i
could find the the bandwidth to do so or
just um the the time away from the other
projects that i want to do i do would
love for molecule to format as a graph
doesn't uh to give you a nice um
uh
raft when you when you click on it
okay fine all right so that's something
we need to
put in the project list basically as a
thing to to make happen
um okay so atom list
is a list of atoms and so what i would
be able to say then
oh that's a little confusing because if
i have a graph
right then it's vertex list then i can
map over the vertex list to say what to
do
for every particular
right given a name of a vertex
i can say what its label should be
that won't work here
unless i want to say
every carbon atom i mean can i do that
and saying atom labels goes to atom of c
goes to blah blah blah
like every carbon atom gets of this
yes and like in other patterns too you
could do um
formal charge goes to uh greater than
zero
to get uh positively charged atoms
okay
all right i mean this seems
uncontroversial this molecule property
thing seems fine
um
okay
multiple labels
and this so this is also something i
mean this is
an extension of what uh graph plot oh my
gosh
well that's something graft plot might
like to have too
so well so no uh so they do uh so you
can specify um so that example with the
b and the the d like above and below
that is taken directly from uh
vertex labels really that works in
vertex labels who knew yes okay
okay fine i didn't know actually until i
went to uh
to set it up
and when i saw how much work there
that's when i knew i had to to piggyback
off of their work rather than trying yes
um
okay what is this
what is this
i'm sorry what is this wait which one
are we this what sorry this one here oh
i mean so that one's is is a little
silly um um let's see so
so any atom with an atomic number
greater than six gets labeled by i can
see what i mean i can read the code i'm
just asking what the semantics of what's
going on here is
right so that atom is a pat is a pattern
and it matches certain uh
elements in there and then the other one
the underscore
how can it match that isn't a pattern i
mean this is a pattern
how is this a pattern
so it's
a pattern is accepted by uh molecule
substructure fine molecule substructure
uh molecule plot
um
wow
so it's it's or you could think it's a
query atom i guess uh
but it describes um
i think of it as a pattern but it is not
a wolfram language pattern
okay
because i mean in general um
language patterns don't allow you
don't have a method for describing um
patterns in a graph
or at least i i did this was the best i
could think of when we
what are you talking about wait a minute
yes yes graph rewriting is complicated
that's what our whole physics project
has
you know provided lots of both tools and
and conceptual technology for
um and we are about to talk about
chemical reactions as graph rewriting
um but we'll come to that
i mean
look in the end absolutely we're going
to want to specify
things with molecules as
you know
molecule transformations are graph
rewriting
but i don't think this is graph
rewriting this just a vertex condition
right this is not a graph there's not a
condition on a graph this is simply a
condition on i mean even i don't know
whether you even have a valence for
example if i wanted to say
all atoms with valence larger than two
or something can i do that
i believe so
with some other one of these wacky
properties
is that right i mean i believe uh either
valence or atom valence i would uh
okay but but fine but so these are local
properties
of i mean i think this is a little weird
but but i mean
i understand why it's desirable to have
these kind of
oh
gosh
reason this is problematic is that the
official pattern for this would be what
is the atom it will be atom of
whatever its element whatever the
element is
and then it would say
um you know slash semicolon
you know
uh
atomic number of elements well it would
be more like molecule property
um
of
you know atomic number
and that whole thing of lm
you know greater than six
that's the that will be the more
official pattern way to write it
but then you even there you run into
troubles because some of those would be
like valence and valence is not a
property of the atom it's a property of
the action i realize i understand that i
understand that so it's a it's a mess
and that that surveillance case is a
case where you do have to admit that
this is embedded within a graph
um
look i consider this fairly hacky but i
think it's still useful and it's
probably a decent shorthand which
there's no reason to attack
michael do you have any particular
comment on this
i agree and similar to the discussion
that we had a couple years ago for
entity poverty and related things yeah
uh
when and how to refer to the secret
condition i agree it's not 100 but i
think it's useful and natural
yeah all right okay fine
okay
chemical formula
what is this
that's probably the most useful one for
beginning people
so we do get a lot of que we have a way
to represent the uh
just an um unspecified uh chemical form
or a specified chemical formula without
uh
without
reference to a molecule in alpha and it
allows us to answer a lot of questions
and so this is the uh bringing so yeah
basically this is basically smiles to
formula is that right
no smiles really has to hold bonding
here we typically don't have the bonding
we just know what's inside
right we we in the end we just know the
elementality and then that's enough to
answer a lot of questions
so this is just the textual version
of that formula
but i don't understand if i want to no
no no not quite
like like normally what we see in a
textbook is a chemical formula
and there are multiple molecules that
might match absolutely yeah
so what i'm saying is how do you enter
chemical i mean to me
there's a chemical formula here
which is
apart from the factorization of this
piece here
is just
a you know it could be an association
that just contains element names and uh
and um
uh
you know
and counts
correct
great and i mean that would be
underspecifying like in this case
there's a little bit more than trusted
tally because of the subscript three
so you can look at the expression tree
of that is
touch more than the zombie
okay explain chemical formulas to me for
a second okay so when when
this business about factoring groups of
atoms
the two operations in a chemical formula
are as i understand it
the multiplicity of the atoms here and
the multiplicity of collections of atoms
is that correct
yes
there is also some bonding implied so
for example that chlorine is bonded to
the bismuth and the thing in parentheses
is also bonded to it it's not specified
but it's implied
right but we don't have a way to at the
moment um what do you call it uh
to go from the formula to the structure
there would be special cases where we
could do that but we don't we haven't
coded those up or anything
um
okay so hold on a second so what i don't
really understand
the notation of chemical formulas as
such i mean what is the what you have
here
is something where there's a shorthand
input which is this just the string
but what is the full
structure of chemical formula
so it i mean it's um
it's not
something
it's uh let's see so it is just a
grouping with a list of um you know so
h5 as uh i mean i'm not sure that's
right
so okay so if i just say this
okay so my question is is this the right
representation
it seems like a very weird
representation to me
so i'm not
yeah let's see i only chose it out of
convenience that
i'm not
what really is a chemical formula what
is the grammar of chemical formulas
let's see um
so i think it's similar it's it's what
we're seeing here but you could imagine
it being a hierarchical structure that
there would be instead of so i use list
here but you could replace list with
chemical formula every all the way down
basically except for this this idea of
um
something being multiplied by a number
and so in alpha i i get
so look it's a bit like trees
well except for this multiplicity
concept
hmm
let me ask you again i'm sorry and there
was this comment about bonds
and i don't didn't quite understand that
in what sense is this formula i mean if
i say h2o
and if i said oh two
are those like just conventionally
different or do they mean something
slightly different
oh those are technically the same
but we write it as h2o because uh
because of conventions
the chemist's use for the exam
okay so so you know
if i were to enter that string in a
different order or something or you you
know what order you want like i say ch
something or other rather than hc
something or other so you have an
implicit set of orderings for the atoms
is that true
yes there are rules from the iupac
killer living is one particular example
okay but so what what is the encoding of
bonds then
well so for that particular formula
there you
from looking at that you can tell that
bit smith is the central and that there
are three um
three phenyl groups coming off of it
and then two chlorines coming off the
central how do you know that i'm sorry
what's that what's happening
okay
that's what chemists do i mean let's say
something
okay let's say that wasn't bismuth i
don't know pick a random rare earth with
valence 5 or something
okay and so it has five arms coming off
it how would you write that string
so i i i tend not to to write the
structural formulas i just go for the
hill formula where everything is written
in in orders um
there are limitations to this
pseudo-hierarchical pseudostructural
variation on on a linear notation
there are shortcomings and when there
are shortcomings generally they don't
try to represent five separate
attachments they'll just resort to the
hill formula what is the hill formula uh
carbon first then hydrogen and then
alphabetically the remaining atoms
with no atoms included more than once
okay so it's just an inventory it's the
thing that we were talking about before
essentially just an association of
counts
basically
okay
so again i'm coming back to this again
what is the
okay so so the order matters here
and so for example could i have another
could this be you know whatever it is
c6h53bi
and then c2h whatever seven or something
on the other side i could repeat the
carbons in different places here is that
correct
so yes i mean as i've written it like
this this object does not um
it doesn't normalize it doesn't really
even check you could enter
um
you can enter things in generally so so
that's a valid kind of thing correct
yes but i imagine when you go to look
for a molecule that matches it you might
not uh find one
no i really matching is purely done
on the uh element counts on the hill
formulas
okay
okay
okay let's okay let me loop around this
again i'm trying to
understand okay
people are gonna and people are gonna
machine generate the innards of a
chemical formula
we need to have some internal
representation
that isn't
you know
that isn't completely silly
in terms of of how that look because
this seems pretty arbitrary to me
this does not seem readily machine
generatable
because it's got all kinds of
you know naked atoms here and you know
all kinds of weird stuff but if your
machine generated would you not machine
generate a molecule rather than a
formula
and so the vast majority of information
yes but well okay but you might want a
formula let's say you're doing
stoichiometry or something and all you
care about is the formula
wouldn't it be nice to be able to get
you know from this thing to be able to
derive what you need for stoichiometry
with an easy piece of code rather than
having to go and i mean
deriving
that for this is a mess
isn't it
so i so i use that because it maintains
the hierarchical structure and it um
um
but and it does it allows you to
faithfully represent the stuff that they
come in if i were to programmatically
generate them then um then i might just
enter in so it should eat
an association like as a first argument
carbon goes to three hydrogen goes to
this and that would be the easiest way
to which is a hill formula like thing
from what you're describing right
correct
okay
but so getting out of chemical formula
getting out that association also seems
like a desirable thing to be able to do
and i mean
yeah
i see element counts is that is that
what's saying
okay
a large fraction of basically especially
in the world from alpha
area of usage of people put in chemical
formulas positive molecules
and that's troublesome when they do
control equals when we have um
let's see an alpha when the number of
isomers is far larger than we're going
to offer as alternatives as um did you
mean
then uh um
then we just parsed to the formula in
that case there is no wolfram language
representation and so the control equals
um does
and there are still many things that can
be on those like masses and other things
all right again i'm going to push this
one more time can anybody think of any
other underlying representation of this
chemical formula that is perhaps a bit
more principled than this
so i can take that to the drawing board
so if we agree that this is a useful
function uh and the the ins and outs
work i can
i can consult others on the uh okay but
maybe we should just brainstorm for a
second more moody tree
yeah i was wondering about that but i
you know we're doing him
trees no we don't have such a thing
um multi-tree is that like is that a
forest or is that no forest is a set of
trees okay
well
okay so i mean
even just doing something that involves
you know c arrow six
would that be better
or is that not any better i feel like
that's actually less consistent because
like in the earlier one the h5
the comma 5 is consistent with the comma
3 which is out
and this one i feel like looks a little
bit unusual to me
and are you happy with the naked with
this one here with the one are you happy
with not having that canonicalized to bi
comma one
the just says
everything is a pair
and
yeah everything is a pair and it either
has a list as its first element or a
or or
you know
presumably or a um
an entity okay fine i i think that i'm
okay with that i think that's possible
at least i actually the common one that
makes it more consistent
fine
okay okay now let's talk about the blue
background which i don't really buy
um
right i i'm i uh was we'll absolutely
after your uh input i was definitely
planning to go to design on it one thing
i like entity formatting type formatting
for this one thing that i like that
entity does
is when it goes when it breaks out into
it goes from being an output cell to an
input cell
it tells you now that it's an entity but
i don't have that working uh here
um
what do you mean it tells you it's
identical so if you take an entity like
if you go into that output type gets
edit
i thought
i thought too too
no thank you best
the the front weight changes
yeah
i didn't think you'd add another thing
but okay so the question is what is the
what do we have what is the graphical
represent you know the graphical
indication of a molecule
i mean it's just a summary box right now
but it says molecule
i don't know that
i think you
i would not go with some kind of blue
yet another color type thing
i mean especially since there's a
formula right there
i would go with some kind of my
flat gray box like this rather than a
bordered thing given that you you are
used to seeing formulas there
and then maybe go ahead should it have a
head like uh
with uh with hard brackets uh when it
formats is chemical formula of
this gray box i don't think it should no
but not for output okay conceivably
i don't think it should
and i think when you say master that's
really kind of i
whatever i mean if that's useful to say
that fine but it should also say it's a
chemical formula
before it starts telling you its mass
um
uh okay see we have all kinds of
comments on our live stream which i
haven't had a chance to look at here um
there's comments about
about canonicalization of chemical
formulas
of which there is none basically it's
what you type in is what you get
right and then you can ask for the hill
formula and you get back an object with
head chemical formula with them in the
the most canonical order that we know
okay
okay
but then i could take this presumably
and i could feed that to chemical
formula
and it would give me
a whole formula chemical formula is that
right
yes that is what it uh we'll do after
okay let me do soon okay
all right and then then if i say
molecule of so if i say for example
chemical formula
about the only one i know let's do
um
i'm so embarrassed about this
ch4 i tend to go for just for that i'm
gonna do that just for fun
um and now i say molecule of that
is that even a thing yeah so that's
where i don't know i mean just a priori
you can't know
you could make a molecule of
disconnected atoms but that's usually
not what people would want okay what
isn't that a real thing isn't that
calcium carbonate or am i totally
confused this one i know is a real
molecule
okay so
right so if you go a little bit down i
think some of what you want to do comes
just a couple lines down
so you can ask for its entity list and
that would be all of the entities in the
knowledge base that have the same
formula
or uh you can generate um not generate
you can look
to outside sources
for iso
psi
i mean that's terribly complicated for
cases like h2o well we know there's a
single i mean okay question that does
sound reasonable i mean it's well
so it yeah when are there when how often
will there only be one isomer or is it
only for totally trivial molecules
that'll be one isomer and as soon as you
get beyond that it'll be like tons of
them
yeah in for
uh it's common to have multiple isomers
it gets combinationally explosively
quick
okay but is there an obvious canonical
molecule to return from a chemical
formula
for some of them they're they're
definitely
yeah
with diatomics and some triatomics all
the single atomic cations and neutral
species obviously but once you get
beyond once you're into the triatomics
it gets
problematic quickly
i mean some molecule doesn't tend to
call interpreter but you could
molecule could do that it could
um to find just one it could call
interpreter on the formula and if it
receives back an entity then return that
but i feel like there would be so many
times disappointing that
you might want not to do it for the few
cases where it can be uniquely done
i don't know people are going to want to
do this they're going to want to take
the formula and say give me a molecule
based on that formula
that's an open problem in computational
chemistry periods
what
doing just what you said
what about
random instance two argument forms
what
what that's crazy michael i mean it's
entertaining
a crazy you know you pick a random
isomer that's what you're saying exactly
no that's crazy yeah i mean it's
entertaining but um
i mean also in general like so if we're
calling the knowledge base we basically
we
we get all of the entities uh in the
list and then we pick a random one from
it
the same with with pubchem or with
we're looking at an external library
that can generate them okay so that one
i mean give me an example where there's
more than one if i say
c1014
or
okay
spin spin spin what's it doing
oh my gosh right what am i doing
it's gone bonkers what is it doing
that was extremely unsavory so the
wolfram alpha parse is to uh formula
molecule of that and one of the pods is
all the isomers that we have
and so that's part of the purpose here
is to
to return um a good
result
in that case
okay you you were defining some cases
where it is a slam dunk to get the
molecule from the formula
right that might be those might be the
cases where interpreter of chemical of
that
um just returns one one thing well i
understand that i understand it but so
so one thing we could do is at least
molecule of chemical formula for those
slam dunk cases would work and for the
other cases it would say multiple
isomers use blah blah blah
that seem reasonable least allows
molecule of chemical formula h2o to work
and i mean for the it could be fast too
we could just keep a uh what do you call
it um
a hash table in the
backlit
okay easy ones
um
right so comments here about people
asking about
alpha fold and language and yes things
like that are
hopefully coming that is a different
meeting about biosequences
this is we're only dealing with ordinary
molecules here there was an earlier
question about hemoglobin
and the representation of how do we
represent
a thing like that where there's a you
know
i don't even know what you guys call
that i mean where there's an atom just
hanging out in a cage in a molecule what
is that called what is that
you know what i'm talking about
you have a protein and has some random
you know like like vitamin b12 or
something has a cobalt
a metal complex if you will
that's what it's called okay overall
it's called a complex i don't recall
what the metal atom would be if it has a
special name
okay but but do we have a way of
representing something like that
not yet we've been talking about some
additional bond types so that we can
handle that and that atom would then be
anchored to the coordinating heteroatoms
with the lone pairs on them but no
formal bonds
what does that mean i mean so because
right now we have a graph that
represents where things have bonds
what do we do okay naive question what
do we do for ionic
know molecule type things what does it
look like what's that we don't draw a
bond so nacl is just n a space
cl with the appropriate plus and minus
is superscripted
right it's a couple it's a couple of
disconnected graphs i see so it's got is
that what would happen with this metal
complex things as well or not not
necessarily
it depends if you have coordinates i
mean that's when
so if you have if you import the thing
with coordinates then you can uh but
doesn't nacl have coordinates as well
not generally i mean you'll find nacl in
a crystal structure
yeah and and that is another thing that
we need a different a a different
representation besides molecule okay
naive question i mean are there bigger
ionically bonded molecules
yeah something like sodium sulfate the
the sulfate has got covalent bonds
between the sulfur and the oxygen but
between the sodium
and the sulfate ion it's an ionic
bond okay but generally in things which
we consider to be individual molecules
there's typically only one ionic bond or
there can be a molecule that's made of
zillions of ionic bonds and not a
crystal so to speak
well not a zillion but
but a handful would not be unreasonable
you know sodium sulfate for example
there are two sodium atoms involved
so there would be two ionic bonds as it
were i see but sodium sulfate though is
it comes in a crystal structure though
generally right i mean it's not
you wouldn't molecule wouldn't be the
best way to represent sodium sulfate
well it depends it depends on the
application right
but i'm just for 3d plotting for
instance
okay now you've questioned guys what you
this is so naive i'm really embarrassed
but you dissolve salt and water right
nacl water
do the nas and the cl's hang out near
each other or do they no they're
hydrated by water molecules they have a
still of water molecules around them and
they can actually direct up to two
layers of shells of waters yes
okay so in other words they really don't
hang out together
not anymore no no the closest you'd get
would be in the gas phase
it would be even
confusing steven as bob just said you
can make nacl a single molecule it's a
very shallow binding but it's a purely
covalent binding it's no longer an ionic
binding
molecule
oh and that's what in the gas phase is
that what's happening
if they get close enough together that
that would be the case yeah if you put
sodium you know if you put salt for
example in a mass spectrometer
but so
but otherwise the the standard thing is
a crystal i mean with the ionic bond you
would expect
you get lots of nacls all in a crystal
structure yeah that's kind of yeah
generally yep yeah yeah
and so we've got uh yeah and so bob uh
and myself also we've been working on
wolfram language representations of that
yeah that came from last
last summer's uh
summer school project right
right
okay and is that going what's that going
to be roughly i mean is it going to be
crystal structure of blah blah blah
uh i think we were calling it crystal
the last time we looked at the code but
it's been a while since i've i've worked
on it and claudio has been busy with
other stuff
okay but so
so i mean but there's a crystal which is
an abstract crystal and it's a crystal
with actual sodiums and chlorines in it
and so on yep
okay
and and then
what's the interface between the
chemistry oh boy this is getting
complicated i mean then we have to deal
with things like surfaces and so on
presumably
is sort of yeah uh there's no direct
connection right now
we've been working on something for the
function repository that we give the
basic pieces to to uh import
a cif file
and then be able to render it um and
then expand the crystal lattice in
various directions by right so many unit
cells and so on so the cif has a single
unit cell energy but cif has multiple
unit cells it basically it's the unit
cell generally they're a bit expanded so
that they have whole molecules instead
of fractional molecules
uh but it has all the symmetry core uh
symmetry transformations encoded in it
so the whole lattice can be generated
from the information and that's what we
do
interesting okay
uh
okay all right let's talk about what on
earth is this g thing
what is that g thing oh so that j that
uh specifies that it's in the gas phase
oh
gosh again something that uh that is uh
very uh useful when writing out uh
chemical reactions
jason is that subscripted it shouldn't
be it's probably uh yes yeah i um yeah
that that's an oops no you're definitely
gonna be uh in the loop on the
formatting wait wait wait a second
wednesday you're saying it shouldn't be
a subscript
no it should be immediately following
the end of the formula
okay why don't we do it in a different
color or a different gray level or
something
that sounds good yeah that would be nice
i mean i believe that
it's probably similar to how we do it in
alpha
okay
but now
in terms of the underlying data
structure here
i assume
it's gone
where is it
the gas evaporated or something
oh um
right so
so
let's see so right now it's it appears
in an annotation rules option because i
didn't know where to put it in that uh
that structure well what other kinds of
annotations can there be charge or
um charge or phase
and how do you do charge for for in a in
a for an ion in a molecule how are you
specifying charge
so in a molecule the charges have to go
on the atoms themselves
and that's done by doing what atom and
then formal charge error blah yeah
and so here this is for the whole
molecule
that's
correct
okay so what's the most analogous thing
to what we're doing with atoms and other
molecules in terms of these annotations
so
i mean do we use annotation rules for
something else or not
no and so actually so right now if you
look at the uh
if you look at the usage my plan was um
the input form that right now would have
it in an annotation rules option but i
don't think that's
the correct thing to do i think the if
the usage that i printed above
that i uh has a second argument so it
would get put into a second argument
being the charge so that makes sense
that seems fine
that seems fine i mean you should be
able to have something more beautiful
than a i mean
i would have thought a a paren
gas or something in very small letters
would be a nice way to do that
and less obscure
unless that's such a common usage that
so we'll check we'll consult with comic
uh let's see i almost said comic books
no uh textbooks uh but actually uh jason
is very familiar with the uh uh iupac's
standards on this and so that's where
we'll okay all right fine
okay
great
um
all right
onward here
so having gone
so just quickly if we have a chemical
formula then it becomes very useful to
know whether it matches a given molecule
which is why
we have this um
well what about molecule match q of
molecule
what is molecule equivalent q
so that was the uh introduced in 12.0 to
tell if two molecules match each other
basically
as in match
in what sense their bond pattern is the
same
let's see yeah so if you find an iso
isomorphism and you rearrange the atoms
in molecule two to be in molecule one
then they would be the same molecule so
it's the analog of graph isomorphism for
molecules
right
is it in fact graph isomorphism or is
there some kind of weird chiral thing
going on
so so they need to be isomorphic they
need to have the the same
stereochemistry and the same um uh the
same atom types and bond types
okay i mean so there is more stuff than
a graph because the stereochemistry
okay
um
but currently we have no way of if if
given a molecule pattern you can tell
whether a molecule uh is it contains it
so if you had a molecule of octane and a
molecule pattern
of
four carbons bonded together then
molecule contains q would give you yes
this this contains that but there's no
way of looking at a pattern and saying
does this molecule right so you could
have a pattern that was eight carbons
together and the ma the actual molecule
octane
and because
they me it
because the molecule contains the
pattern and the pattern matches every
single heavy atom on there we would say
that they match
well yeah so so you're saying here
molecule is just a straight molecule
with isomorphism and chemical formula i
understand what that is that that's does
this in this molecule pattern
does that mean this molecule pattern
represents some version of the whole
molecule or some subpart of the molecule
it represents um
the whole molecule um
aside from heavy atoms or aside from
hydrogens
i mean the pattern could include uh
hydrogens but
doesn't necessarily need to i get it
yeah a pattern can be a part of a
molecule it can be an exact molecule or
it could be a family of molecules that
are related based on on the pattern but
if it's part of a molecule molecule
match q
will only match if the thing on the
left-hand side the first argument is
just that fragment
right it's not a molecule contains q
right yeah fine
looks good to me
um
so those are in red because they they're
not merged into this branch and they
don't work yet all right okay the
variety of comments on our live stream
here which i want to
just look at
uh various things about graph neural
networks
yes
graph neural networks yeah i mean we're
working on graph neural networks just
coming it's coming
um
um
comments about biochemistry lots of
machine learning models exist i don't
know whether we've got ones in the in
the neural net repository yet for for
biochemistry do we
i don't think so but yes there are some
that might be an interesting i mean
who's going to be responsible for those
is going to be the chemistry team or the
machine learning team machine learning
team
we have not any meetings
it comes down to like i mean how how do
you featurize it and then once you know
how you featurize it then how do you
build your nets around to work with
those features and so to me that that
means a combinat a cooperation between
so maybe
of course maybe there needs to be a
discussion with i don't know citra i
think is the person dealing with the
neural net repository these days
there's some discussion with the machine
learning team with julio he has an
intern who wants to do something like
this okay you want to see what's coming
out of this
but generally it cannot be the chemistry
team because the chemist system is not
much involved with machine learning
machine learning is not much involved
with chemistry yes
so you can advise you can advise well so
there i mean
yeah so i think the the molecule the
chemist the molecule stuff is becoming
uh mature enough that it can can meet
the machine learning so
i mean previously it was a little it was
a little uh it was a little early
in the latest version we have the
features but we already have some kind
of maybe maybe there is still the
reaction to be done which is a
non-deliverable subject and we have
today right that's uh and so um okay
let's see and so one thing we're sliding
by here i i have some options there for
molecule match queue that i uh feel they
look reasonable to me okay i don't
exactly know what resonance
that that's this case here right
whether it's yes whether to care about
that order
exactly
so in this i mean it it's here you would
inc um
so it's up to you guys whether it would
be uh include resonance structure but i
feel like resonance is just the concept
of uh of uh delocalized uh bonds being
in resonance with each other and so
include stereochemistry
is whether to take account of
stereochemistry yes include resonance
does that mean whether to take account
of resonance as in to cause this thing
to be the same as the one with its
double bonds in the opposite place
exactly yes that seems reasonable to me
okay um
let's see the comments from richard on a
live stream about
self-referencing self-referencing
embedded strings selfies
anybody know about this oh yeah no i
definitely um let's see uh
yeah so i would like to write a um an
encoder for that in wolfram language so
you it's like smiles but it's useful in
machine learning because um so you can't
just break up a smiles chunk into little
pieces
and learn anything useful from it
because you've got all these um
these pieces that depend far back into
the uh right it's context dependent
whereas this is some kind of context
independent that sounds interesting yeah
there's a python implementation that i
would like to to study and then uh uh
fair enough yeah okay machine learning
net encoder stuff will be a separate
meeting next week hopefully
okay all right chemical reactions right
so uh so we keep i've we've been
thinking about this for a long time and
i keep thinking that uh uh that there
are two different use distinct use cases
that that are that exist and so that's
why i keep thinking of it as two
different uh objects
so one of them
so the chemical reaction represents a
single uh
an actual instance of a reaction where
you have actual chemicals combining and
making products
that's what the normal person thinks of
the non-chemistry comment from richard
here that every selfie string is a valid
chemical that's interesting and
non-trivial not obvious how that could
possibly be true
but okay so it's a representation of
graphs that has
well interesting okay
all right i'm sorry so that's what i
remember it it allowed you to tokenize
the the string and then rearrange it in
chunks and come up with a valid molecule
where you couldn't do that with smiles
yes
jason please send me a reference on that
will do thank you
yeah send me send it to me
um
so here uh again i went for the same uh
formatting as above and i'm open to
suggestions there that okay hold on hold
on i'm trying to understand this even
basically i mean to me
we were just talking about this in a
different discussion
you know
comical reactions are like graph
rewriting
not quite
it is exactly this distinction between
this first one and the template above
okay
all right so
okay
let's let's just get some basic things
so there's sort of formula level
representations of reactions and there
are presumably structure level
representations of reactions is that a
true statement or is that a bad
distinction
i think it's orthogonal there's um
the the graph based one
which is the templates and then there is
the second example here that jason has
which is an exact reaction that you
would use in the laboratory to make
something
i think that's more of a the practical
distinction between the two what what is
an exact reaction versus a i didn't
understand so in other words you you
would have you know instead of just
saying an esterification reaction with
some carboxylic acid and some alcohol
you would have the reaction for
esterifying benzoic acid with
isopropanol
basically it's the difference between
having particular
uh molecules that you're acting versus
uh
genetic uh templated uh molecules that
you don't necessarily care about what's
attached
it will be all named the action of the
persons are of this type of
generic
right so uh so what i wrote was alkene a
generic alkene dimerization you can
write as a as a pattern and i i'm not
familiar enough with what graph
rewriting means to say if it's
equivalent or not but it is it's a
structural transformation where you have
mappings between the vertices on the
left and the right
uh versus just a
an instance of that when it's after it's
been applied to a set of molecules okay
so there's a whole literature and a
whole set of people
who've been
doing sort of graph rewriting
to represent molecules and that
that
sort of world has intersected with the
world of stuff we're doing in the
physics project
and you know that world also intersects
with category theory
and a whole bunch of other sort of
pieces
um
and uh
it feels like that approach is a very
nice clean general approach to this kind
of thing and one that we should be
kind of trying to make use of because
that will allow us to do you know for
example theorem proving for molecules
right right
and that's that's great at that level
there but the second use here of expl
you know
an exact instance of a molecule is would
be something more that would be useful
for like uh wolfram alpha it would be a
result there where you're looking for
something particular
and
uh you know you would have lots of data
about the particular reaction
uh and again that's that's what you know
jason has in the second
uh use case here okay so what we've got
is the i don't know these name reaction
type things which are template-ish
reactions we've got specific instances
of those reactions and then i do love
the fact that you've got a proposed
thing called called reaction apply i
mean if these things aren't
transformation rules i don't know what
it
is
so that i mean the example there is uh
where i define the pattern i mean that's
a more complicated one but uh that's
where you define the the reaction of one
amino acid joining another one and
making a peptide
and then you
apply it to a list of molecules and and
get back
the list
okay so hold on
that
i'm so confused here
all right so this is saying
this amino acid how are we labeling the
atoms i mean so
again and maybe i'm just again very
confused about
basic
ideas of chemistry so we've got a carbon
atom it's on the left-hand side of a
reaction you know let's say we have a
molybdenum atom you know a unique
molybdenum atom sitting on the left-hand
side of a reaction eventually that's
going to wind up you know somewhere in
the structure on the right-hand side
great we can kind of trace that
molybdenum atom now let's say we have
two molybdenum atoms
can we label do we are we in the way
that the level that people describe
chemical reactions do you label those
molybdenum atoms or not
so they are and and the example right
here shows that that's what the colon
followed by an integer is
it's the mapping from the reactants on
the left-hand side to the products why
can you always do that in the world of
quantum
mechanics in other words well
particularly with one of those resonance
structure things or something else i
mean is it always the case that you can
just trace there's where the atom went
so no oftentimes you don't like
oftentimes like you have a real life
reaction and you
you have a an idea about the mechanism
and then and that allows you to to
rationalize what's going on but then
oftentimes people don't then go from
that that uh
that
mechanism that they intuitively
understand to writing out an actually
adam mapped reaction and so actually
having a fully mapped
reaction that fully makes sense is
i find it rather rare i mean
okay
and they're often not mechanism-based
idealization if you will yeah it's
really nice
so in in a to make a reference that some
at least you know
like in in something like quantum field
theory particle physics whatever you
would have
you know for example you have i don't
know
two quarks scattering of two quarks or
something you know you will have
different finding diagrams that exchange
them don't exchange them etc and
are you saying that in reactions you can
imagine the same kind of thing that
those two carbon atoms there are
essentially different feynman diagrams
that represent two different reaction
mechanisms one in which those two
identical carbon atoms were exchanged
and one in which they were not is that a
true statement
and and you don't i don't think so i
think it depends on the reaction in the
question
of course all carbon atoms are the same
the thing and the wave function is
anti-symmetrical symmetry size in the
carbon atom practically they are really
different one they don't switch
yeah if they have different environments
they would certainly
behave differently in a reaction
okay so when people want to to study the
mechanism of a reaction they'll use
isotope labeling they'll put it and you
see they they don't
wherever there's a seed they end up just
in a few places
okay i understand so this is like
this is kind of
gives a lie to quantum mechanics that is
these things are really not it's as if
that when you say they have an
environment it's as if they're sort of
being measured somehow
they are measured by the electrons and
by the radiation that is exactly what
stabilizes them
i mean how many how many uh protons and
neutrons and electrons do you need to be
to be uh
macroscopic i guess well no but that's
not what's happening i mean there's this
notion
okay naive physics question here
there's you know quantum zeno effect
when you have continual measurement is
that effectively what happens in these
chemistry situations or what i think
that's not unrelated indeed
so that's why you can maintain the
identity of a carbon atom is because
you're sort of quantum zenoing it all
the time
i've not heard this concrete formulation
but i believe this is correct yes
i think this goes back to
armond fifa in the late 80s in edh
interesting okay
i want to measure this quantum zeno
effect because i think it will allow us
to measure a bunch of parameters in our
model of physics
but um
i wonder if it's been measured in
chemistry
um in any case
uh
okay
so one thing that's really going to be
that we've found is it's it's kind of
troubling to or not troubling it's
onerous to enter in these reactions with
all of the the atom mapping and so in
the next version uh extending molecule
draw
to allow um
in manual uh atom labeling where you
just like
so so some type of automatic labeling
saying hey there's only one molybdenum
atom on each side so we're just going to
map those to each other but here are the
ones we haven't mapped yet uh here's a
graphic where you can click click click
click
um tools like that that perhaps would be
a function repository or perhaps in the
system okay hold on so so but the
fundamental idea here is
we have a chemical reaction which has
either mapped or unmapped atoms
in its
left-hand side and right-hand side
we have some combination of of um
of molecules with multiplicity perhaps
that is mapped into some other
combination of molecules also perhaps
with multiplicity is that a fair
statement
and each of these collections of atoms i
mean at a purely sort of formal level
these are sets in other words it doesn't
matter in a chemical reaction a plus b
is the same as b plus a
correct
so in yes in a in the uh in an actual
chemical reaction it it is uh as to
whether or not like reaction apply
um enforces ordering or not that's
that's something that we have
has been a subject of well you see but
this is like subset replace i mean
basically what you're saying is the
chemical you know if you've got a whole
bunch of chemicals and they're floating
around and you have a reaction that's
available that lets you you know add
chemical a to chemical b it's as if you
were doing a subset replace on the
collection of all possible chemicals
we're just picking out those two
particular ones where
you know where they can be combined
and it's a little tricky thinking about
the multiplicity and you know in the
subset
replace
i mean essentially that's what you're
doing i think with with reaction apply
you've got
look in the end you're going to have a
whole vat of chemicals
and some of them will react and some of
them won't
and that's what reaction apply
presumably reaction apply could have a
bystander molecule sitting there that
isn't involved in the reaction and it
would just affect the molecules that are
actually undergoing the reaction is that
true
it's not set up that way at the moment
but you could envision it that way uh it
seems a little wasteful though to be
throwing in additional elements to the
reaction list that don't participate i
know but but what i'm trying to get at
is i'm telling you there is a more
principled way to think about this which
is what these people who've been doing
category theory and graph rewriting with
these things and so on have been getting
at and i think that we need to i mean
you're you are okay what exactly is it
that
you would like to introduce right now
you've got these two which which one is
the which one is the one you care most
about of these
i mean the template reaction thing
is is the name reaction
as its name suggests it it's a thing
which has not specific kinds of atoms
but templated structures correct
yes so i find template reaction to be a
lot more fun uh
chemical reaction is very important for
the uh education alpha notebook
and wayne efforts yeah for educational
markets
and what you do with it is mostly
psychometry is that true or mostly just
look up of reaction we'll see you
balance you you
finding the limiting reagent when you
when they give grams of
that thermochemistry
yeah
yeah
but so when you're saying
thermochemistry that's just you're just
looking it up you can't compute anything
about that is that true right in general
we would uh call it
a
computer
okay
you're not there yet
so so i mean the thought would be how do
you compute it roughly just just using
free energy things so you know what
well if you have a new reaction that
that you don't have the delta h for the
enthalpy for a reaction and you have
smaller reactions that you do and they
you can add them together to get the
new reaction you you um you do that you
just add them together with the multiple
you know
necessary coefficients to end up your
total thing because enthalpy is a state
function
i understand that but i mean is
is that but it's not a state function if
the it's like like pieces of molecules
can separately interact and you can and
it just adds in that case does it or
does it
i don't think it does in that case i
think it would if the molecules were
separate
if anyway okay fair enough but so there
are
okay
so now gosh
oh my gosh you really gonna use a plus
sign there
oh so
it it doesn't have to i mean obviously
um we just we don't have to um
we wouldn't even have to to use that in
it but there's a good question is there
an algebra of chemistry like this does
it actually work
right if it's three hydrogens and you
know three times hydrogen plus two times
oxygen
if the reaction is balanced it works
but a lot of times people are sloppy and
they don't balance
well i understand that but but the
concept of taking an algebraic formula
and adding in coefficients into that
algebraic formula is not something
completely crazy from an algebraic
formula no it's not crazy
so in other words you're proposing that
we really could have something where
an algebraic-like variable is a
is a chemical
because that's what you're effectively
saying here is that that's what we're
doing
wow
point your points taken but but you must
be very rigorous if you're going to do
that
because but but i mean you could have
something where you just type it in as
you know look we could have something
where it's x plus y plus z
and then we can have a function that
you know
to achieve i don't know let's say you're
making symmetric polynomials or
something you could just type in the
monomials and then you could have a
function that goes and scatters
coefficients in there that's a perfectly
reasonable pseudo-algebraic kind of
function if you see what i mean
what do
the um
boy okay so i must admit i did not
realize what kind of can of worms i was
opening by uh allowing plus i mean i
just thought it would be a convenience
that the user could type plus or well
but that's the point you say hydrogen
plus hydrogen you get two times hydrogen
i mean we haven't you know there is yeah
an algebra
for and it might work okay it might work
the only thing is that i think
okay here's where it will get really
really funky okay let's take that object
there
and um
uh you know this is the point is it's a
linear algebra so to speak it it can't
be you cannot possibly do this
um
you know
this
is bonkers
right oh no okay
yeah i'm going to get get hydrogen
squared
but but the real potential problem with
the plus is what was mentioned earlier
on decide this if we have the
application
do we expect
the
molecules that we apply it to to come in
the order or not because plus might
reorder and you might not be aware of it
plus you will reorder yeah
sometimes it'll just keep it if it's
already altered
right but but you see this is where you
get back to that horror of that chemical
formula thing you had before where
you're getting multiplicities with with
sublists right so the alternative would
be you can represent these things as
lists blah blah blah arrow list blah
blah blah but now and this is why i i
knew my little antennae were wiggling
and we when we were talking about
chemical formula that something was
going to go wrong because this is
because you're going to want to put the
multiplicity
you're going to want to add
multiplicities here
right oh absolutely if uh i know and
then you're going to want to use
something like the chemical formula
multiplicity thing at which point you've
got an ugly data structure that's hard
to deal with well so if you scroll down
uh there's a reaction under
right so there i mean where it just
where it has
the factors out
so
so that's one of our examples in alpha
that uh
jason found that uh
it's a rather difficult one to balance
correct
that's a serious set of different time
equations
even i don't see your potential problem
can you repeat okay so what i'm saying
is
you're
saying let's use chemical formula like
syntax
to represent these chemical reactions
which means that when you're
representing multiplicities you're doing
this kind of hacky thing of saying blah
list blah comma 2.
right so in the in the canon so if if
you did the full form of that one
directly above the cursor it does end up
i believe using lists for
um yeah right i mean so it's that thing
input form of that thing
oh my gosh
no
no you can't do that
look now the multiplicity is before the
chemical formula just because you write
it that way well entertainment
yes but this isn't this is not a
computable thing i mean that 10
is as much like your paren three as
anything right that 10 is really this
chemical thingy paren parenting isn't it
it's ten
molly copies of that molecule whereas
the subscript ones are 10 copies of
those atoms or collections of atoms that
are submolecular
that that's the chemistry convention
from the past 200 years
yes
and you know maybe that's the yeah that
could very well not be computable in
today's modern languages
also
but anyway we don't want people to go in
take this apart we want to supply
software used to do things that's that's
my thought that i mean uh you're saying
this is opaque
yeah this thing
people could do this but
why would you do it
but how do you look if you simply want
to enter that chemical
this thing here how would you enter this
with a string or what
how would you enter that formula
ah so i yeah i don't know how to make
interactive boxes that kind of thing
um
so you mean like like put your cursor in
there
template like input might be very
convenient here indeed
sure i'm just saying if we wanted to
make this
i mean
by the way we have all kinds of
interesting comments on our live stream
and i hope somebody's going to make sure
to
uh store these and send them out to
people please
um
language for biochemical systems
okay there's a hole
yeah
right i've seen a bunch of these these
are these are
things about
can you machine learn what reactions
happen
and yes that is interesting
um although a little bit different from
what we're dealing with here
but this what is this language for
biochemical systems i don't know that
although it may be related to a bunch of
these
uh
um
yeah well okay
um
okay
yes
i think there's a grand unification here
of
um
you know all this
graph rewriting multi-way graphs all
this stuff with chemical reactions and i
know you guys are keen to get
sort of practical things that deal with
the simple cases in there and perhaps we
can do that as experimental functions
um i do think that there's a really nice
unification that can be gotten and i
think that the more we
burn in well
okay so the full form of that reaction
there it could easily just be an
association as opposed to the chemical
formula where you need to to maintain
the hierarchy that the user put in so
there's no reason that the the canonical
form of chemical reaction here
couldn't be an association with the uh
the right-hand side you know it make it
atomic now we can look in anymore
that's that's well i mean i can only
make it the fake kind of atomic which if
you know how to you can look inside
well
um
okay we're running out of time we all
need to continue this
as you expected um
oh boy
but i mean the general idea of two
different um
um
two different uh uh
data structures for this
why why why isn't it just pattern
variables and the chemical reaction so
you could make so that would be the
other alternative would be to have one
object it would be chemical reaction and
if
it had molecule patterns in the as the
the reactants and products then reaction
apply would work
if you didn't have molecule patterns
and had regular uh
molecules and entities
then
reaction balance would work
and so that's the thing that uh um
i could make them one unified thing but
then i would have to have these internal
switches that are always saying are you
a template reaction okay then do this
are you not then do that
right i mean in a template reaction you
would never put a stoichiometric
coefficient exactly because you want to
literally map every atom
yeah you have to do it that way even if
you have two copies of one molecule
being involved for example a
dimerization
they still need to be present
individually the
okay
no i mean i i do understand why that
it's useful to have do different things
give me an analogy though i mean
you know in one case
what are these like
wait the difference between go ahead
well so i mean it's i it seems very much
like a a
string to a string template yeah that
was what i was going to do okay
[Music]
but notice that we're doing that with
patent variables
right i mean the structure of uh the
template
it's is linear it's a one-dimensional
object rather than these graphs
mean string template or string
expression
p mean string expression okay
um
okay richard on livestream is mentioning
bionetgen
which
apparently
compiles well i i think that that is
probably similar to what system model is
doing and by the way does anybody know
when we're dealing with chemical
reactions does anybody know how this
relates to what's been done in system
model with chemical reactions
i'm only familiar with the high school
um
laboratories that they built one is a
modeling a chemical reaction but that's
just a couple right they have much
fancier things that are used by pharma
companies and so on
right a lot of that is i mean it's it's
concerned with the kinetics of uh of
reactions right that uh
well it's concerned in the end with
making odes that represent you know this
concentration that concentration this
rate costs right yeah
yes that's kinetics
right
okay so not this stuff
okay so how do we go from this
representation of a chemical reaction to
saying okay this has rate constant blah
and now i'm going to have this list of
chemical reactions
give me
the whole sort of story of
the you know the reaction network and
its odes and so on well so i have it um
uh tentative at the moment but uh
some of the parameters in this uh the
association that you could give
would be things that we can't
necessarily compute
but that uh you could be used later on
down the line like a reaction rate
my compartmental modeling package could
handle that steven
it would basically take something that
looks very much like a plus b goes to c
plus d
and a and b would be two molecules and c
a d would be two other molecules and
it'd be a rate constant
and you can generate the differential
equation you can have several reactions
in your system and it will it'll
generate the ods for the coupled system
right
boy and that is just like a token event
graph in our other world
fancy that it's like like the mean field
theory of token event graphs
okay fascinating um everything boils
down to zeros and ones doesn't it
yeah but going through graphs and graph
rewriting
um okay there was another comment here
uh
let's see
um
just look at these other comments from k
here
um
right yeah i write i mean this is about
what molecules are and so on
um
there's a webinar which is touching on
this
what is this you mean at the
philosophical level
what the molecule is in the
language is the webinar upcoming if
people are interested we have still
something available
okay no hidden advertisement
okay sorry
let's see richard is making a comment
here
about
yeah i mean this
this whole business about
okay there's also the relation of these
things to petri nets that's another
whole story
which i think i'm finally understanding
anybody else here understand yes
i've used that uh structure for modeling
the chemical kinetics
but without rate constants right petri
nets are just the combinatorics of
what's going on
yes well i'm uh perhaps i'm using a
somewhat uh
perverted ver uh
i mean i call them petri nuts because
you've er you've got a set of nodes that
are the reactants and products and
you've got another set of nodes of the
reactions
that are between them
[Music]
and it's a bipartite graph and it's very
easy to trace stuff out and the reaction
rates are actually held
in the reaction nodes
yeah and it's a directed graph
um
and it's a very convenient way to
represent it i i know petri nets are
also used for modeling information
well right in in the
i just posted this this thing just today
about this whole multi-computation
business yeah um
which in which petri nets come out
as a token deduplication of these token
event graphs which are token event graph
is like the individual molecules
interacting with reactions
and if you conflate all copies of a
molecule together you end up getting a
sort of petri net representation
yep that would be it you know yeah
taking everything that's in the beaker
as it were
right
um
oh okay we're
being pointed to a
a thing called cantera which i've never
heard of anybody heard of that
no no
no
tools well we should look at it thanks
for that pointer
um
this is chemical kinetic stuff looks
like
um
cool
all right i unfortunately have to go and
um
uh
oh okay
yeah i mean look this is a these are
highly interesting subject and one that
i think we should try and solve at a
kind of
a little bit higher intellectual plane
than just
you know the particular kinds of things
that are needed for
sort of educational chemistry so to
speak but we obviously need the
educational chemistry stuff in there and
i think the general direction jason that
you were
uh
you know look it seems fine for this
level
um
and by the way i don't know which of you
uh we are having i think our kickoff
meeting about this whole
multi-computation framework tomorrow
um
and uh
maybe at least some representatives of
the chemistry world should be there
and i think we'll livestream that so
people can
can check that out
uh
all right we should wrap up here thanks
a lot everybody
very interesting stuff thank you for the
folks on the live stream lots of very
good comments much appreciated